[Music]
we live in a universe where
statistically disorder is king as time
moves forward things fall apart stars
burn out energy spreads out entropy
conquers all
but humans life fights that trend we
build things we organize things we add
information so why is it that we love
destroying things exploding fireworks
fights and crashes even popping bubble
wrap tiny cute things can make us want
to just squeeze them to death
why
[Music]
the power to destroy is a delicious one
even just holding this here knowing I
can drop it I am in control
I can exert my will in a dramatic and
irreversible way ready ready
[Music]
beautiful why does that feel so good to
do or even just watch for me throwing it
to its death was almost relaxing like I
feel calmer now after being destructive
like I vented some pent-up energy or
anger why do we like breaking things
when we're angry there is a growing
trend of businesses called anger rooms
that are popping up in places like Texas
and Toronto people pay to visit these
anger rooms and let off steam by
smashing mock-ups of workplaces kitchens
and more catharsis theory proposes that
such acts of destruction reduce our
anger but do they sometimes but
sometimes they don't this is what makes
studying the mind so difficult
researchers are still looking into these
specifics and the variables involved and
I want to see firsthand and in person
what it's like when people get angry and
then break things will they be more or
less violent afterwards
[Music]
to demonstrate catharsis theory we set
up our own anger room to see whether or
not breaking things will help calm down
some angry people our subjects think
they're participating in a study about
opposing political views so we've asked
them to write an essay on different
polarizing topics Hashana hi how are you
I'm Michael it's nice to meet you how is
just with your Co participant Clint he's
in another room I'm gonna give your
essay to Clint and he's gonna critique
it and you're going to critique his okay
each of our subjects has been paired
with a man named Clint and they will be
critiquing each other's essays police
officers have a very difficult job they
had to protect us mainly from people of
color the thing is okay here we go I'm
actually Clint overblown an American get
over it my job or rather a cleanse job
is to make our subjects mad so they can
test our anger room you should be
ashamed you deserve with Pouncy what an
[ __ ]
change the black that's better
okay go Shauna I'm back and you were
with Clint okay now let's go through
what he wrote just quickly he wrote did
I put that that way no you didn't did
you turn it around I did turn it around
he seems like a bigot or somebody want
to keep looking at me he's responded to
your essay there thank you - we can't
tell people where to go to eat for lunch
what car to drive like that just really
irritates me this is a person that is
making arguments that are not based in
any fact he's clearly someone who thinks
that the people who are on social
programs are lazy okay that's a
ridiculous argument disgusting
oh I hope I don't see him in the hallway
he's a dick and that is why he is part
of the reason why our country sucks
right now because he's stupid well I
think that was pretty effective we've
got a lot of angry people on our hands
so we'll demolishing things calm them
down or will acts of destruction throw
fuel on the fire let's explore a
catharsis theory with an expert the
modern view of catharsis is that by
acting out we release sort of like a
pressure valve and that releases that
energy in order for us to sort of build
up again and handle everyday distress
people who are angry and aggressive who
then act that out what would they feel
afterwards what many studies have found
is that it's a short-lived released and
it feels good it feels really good to
release but what happens in the brain is
the brain enjoys that but there's really
a reward to build up that pressure again
and then release it again
it's a temporary fix and as far as we
know I didn't realize it was so
complicated and still being researched I
thought it was black and white it was
you do this and you release the emotion
and it's gone yeah not as much we don't
have this perfect definition of
catharsis where everybody agrees here's
how it works
here's how it ends up well let's see if
catharsis works for us
now that Clint has sufficiently angered
all of our subjects he is more like a
[ __ ] as far as I'm concerned it's time
to put catharsis theory to the test some
subjects will be allowed to actively
take out their anger on all these
beautiful art objects you have
completely free rein to break anything
in this room okay
other subjects are instructed to sit in
the room passively I want you to reflect
on the essay the arguments the critiques
and also on the objects in this room and
maybe Annie Clinton no you are not
that's not part of this study okay well
these subjects feel less angry after
their violent acts of destruction only
one way to find out
[Music]
when we are angry the body's adrenal
glands release cortisol and adrenaline
ready in the body and mind for fight
mode but catharsis Theory hypothesizes
that letting it out relieves feelings of
aggression well these subjects feel less
angry after their violent acts of
destruction before we move on to the
final step of our anger room
demonstration
maybe we can gain insight from someone
who makes a living by hitting not
objects but other people mark Smith aka
rhino is a champion bodybuilder boxer
and UK gladiator who knows a thing or
two about how to destroy an opponent
so when you're going into a fight you
know that you're going to get hurt
yes you know that you're gonna hurt
someone else how do you psych yourself
up to be good at that well you're going
into a fight you want to stick to your
game plan stay focused and be relaxed
relaxed I would have thought you'd want
to go in angry no because if you go in
too angry all you're doing it and you're
not thinking straight back and it turns
into like a school ball so it's a very
tactical game right dyad a tiger like
rocky but this is fascinating to me
because you would think that to
physically out fight someone yes in
nature we would have evolved to run off
of anger and fear that's like sue Lyons
I agree view their two lions attack and
go full-out done they
there's no pace in that fight whatsoever
like animals but you have to know when
to be an animal and at what point in the
fight okay so it's no Prince I'm a very
jumpy country person is now in Wenzhou
called the trigger if you ever find
yourself angry in your real life do you
find it helpful to punch a punching bag
definitely yeah I will get angry like
I'm on the phone with my bank and I
might think slamming a door or just
hanging up and throwing my phone on the
bed no legs or your phone and don't slam
doors why come and exercise and hit the
bag you feel so much better what's the
difference though they're both like well
thing is you're not doing something
spontaneous and acting on impulse and
all right it's premeditated you know
you're gonna go okay I'm gonna pack my
bag on a go to gym you're releasing
endorphins you'll feel more relaxed and
you'll be able to assess the bank
manager who's been irritating you for
the last hour can I can I try hitting
some things definitely you can try it in
me
can i really yes you are you gonna hit
back let you know I'm there don't look
scary
is Rhino correct that violent acts of
Rage won't calm you down
but the controlled aggression used in
boxing will actually relax you I guess
I'm about to find out I came out of the
fight having learned two things one I'm
a wimp and two rhino is right when
physical violence is channeled in an
organized sports like boxing it can
actually reduce feelings of aggression I
have this weird combination of feelings
as tired as I am yeah I'm very amped up
and I beat it
yeah I don't feel aggressive I would say
I'm relaxed here I would just say I'm
clearer here and I feel more in control
I had a tiger rock yeah well maybe it's
the eye of the man that was great
[Music]
it's time for the final part of our
anger room demonstration all of our
subjects will be taking part in what
they think is a reflex test against
their opponent Clint in reality of
course there is no Clint and what we're
really looking at is the catharsis fury
have our subjects levels of anger been
affected according to whether they
committed violent acts of destruction or
not stage 3 is going to be testing how
your reflexes are working at this very
moment okay so this right here is a
static electricity generator that is
going to provide a little bit of a shock
we're putting one on Clint as well and
he's in another room but you both have
the same setup once our subjects are
fitted with the shock bracelet they're
introduced to the Tesla's control panel
yeah it's very simplified but that
really helps keep the variables low so
both you and Clint will be competing in
a bit of a game the yellow light is
going to come on at some point and as
soon as you see it come on hit that
orange button and if you hit this button
before Clint does you'll see the green
light come on and that'll mean that you
won and Clint needs to receive a small
shock okay and you can set this to a
level of your choosing
so okay light goes on if I hit this the
green one comes and then I'm allowed to
work at this contraption correct which
controls how high the voltage and for
how long the voltage correct okay if
however Clint pushes the button before
you do the red light will come on
indicating light and I'm about to get it
that you'll that you'll get a shot yeah
correct we'll get a sense of our
subjects level of anger by how they
respond to the chance to administer pain
to Clint
remember this subject just sat in the
anger room passively did I get it
oh all right the green light means our
subject wins how hard will he shock
Clint I'm gonna give you a little low
one buddy there you go
just a kiss got me the red light means
Clint won
how will our subject respond to getting
shocked not only does this subject not
seem angry he's actually enjoying the
game all right about that I'm not gonna
harm you man yellow one he actually
seems relatively calm will our other
passive subject follow suit Clint gave
her a painful shock let's see how
strongly she retaliates even after
getting a shock from Clint this subject
is still hesitant to give him a shock in
return okay Clint Andrea okay it's just
a reminder that you are you are allowed
to change that dial to what you think
would be appropriate yeah I just don't
want to like hurt him or anything I'm
just gonna keep it at low so the angry
subjects who sat passively seem to have
calmed down now it's time to check on
the subjects who acted violently in the
anger room did letting out all of that
aggression relieve their anger the
experiment will begin now
[Music]
take it take it take it
kahshanna that's the best that's fine
what level is your die lat
[Music]
he crepe that all the way up and he's
laying on that button this subject was
one of the most aggressive people in the
anger room but that doesn't seem to have
calmed him down
[Music]
among our subjects it seems that those
who physically vented their anger are
still pretty angry compared to the
subjects who sat quietly so at least in
this case catharsis therapy was not
effective in fact in some cases the
subject seems even angrier you know
that's too hard you dick why don't you
come in here talk to me in person oh my
god oh my god we're all familiar with
the concept of rubber necking it's hard
to look away from a car crash oh my god
oh but why there are surely a myriad of
reasons but one may be that at a
primitive level witnessing danger allows
us to learn and prepare for it
activities where danger and destruction
are likely are exciting starting in our
childhood physical aggression is
encouraged even in games take a pinata
for example as a special birthday treat
we are told to beat up an effigy with a
baseball bat and when we hit it hard
enough we are rewarded with candy what
parts of a child's urge to destroy our
innate versus learned well there was a
groundbreaking experiment that shed
light on this in 1961 Albert bandura
conducted a famous and controversial
study called the Bobo doll experiment he
had adults act violently to an
inflatable clown doll in the presence of
children then left the children alone
with the same doll to see if they would
mimic the destructive behavior they'd
observed
disturbingly the children did indeed
copy the adults and lashed out at the
doll often getting very creative with
their aggression and destruction
aggression comes in many unexpected
forms why is it so hard to resist
popping bubbles in bubble wrap for
instance do we like the sound the
destruction or both it's like we're
naturally drawn to destroying these
harmless plastic bubbles of air
destructive tendencies seem to be so
ingrained in us that we even respond to
positive stimulation with urges to
destroy one of the strangest things
about destruction is how people want to
hug things to death especially things
that are extremely cute like a puppy we
don't know exactly why this is but there
is a study that demonstrates the effect
by using bubble wrap and our desire to
pop these bubbles
can sweet adorable stimuli really incite
aggressive behavior we're about to find
out
thank you for participating in our focus
that's different please make yourself
comfortable we've recruited subjects who
think they're taking part in a motor
skills test are you familiar with this
product yes have you popped the bubbles
in bubble wrap before yes but really
what we're testing is their aggressive
response to cute stimuli so you will be
viewing a montage of images these pop
bubbles in the bubble wrap you may pop
as many or as few as you like
just be sure to start when images begin
and stop them the images end popping
bubbles is like squeezing a stress ball
it's a great way to express aggression
the question is will the subjects pop
more bubbles when watching neutral
images or cute ones first we showed our
subjects these basic landscapes which
are not designed to elicit an emotional
response
[Music]
and we tallied the total number of
bubbles pop all right we're gonna do
part 2 where you'll be viewing another
set of images we also showed them images
of puppies don't you just wanna hug them
and squeeze them just okay look you get
the point to keep things even half of
the subjects viewed the landscapes first
and half view the puppies first but I
did wait they seemed to pop a lot more
bubbles while watching the puppies
except for this guy so-called cute
aggression is a universal psychological
phenomenon researchers believe the
brains response to both cuteness and
aggression results in the release of
dopamine implicated in reward and
pleasure if we are unable to physically
touch cute stimuli the desire to do so
can be regulated by substituting
aggressive physical behavior will our
results reflect this theorem
[Music]
lay it out how did you feel about the
images that you saw oh cool how did you
feel about the puppies I love you
they were very tiny and adorable and I
want to talk them and how did you feel
about popping the ball or I felt like I
wanted to play with the dogs or I wanted
to play with a bubble wrap with the dogs
in our simple test our subjects popped
an average of 33 percent more bubbles
while watching cute puppies as opposed
to boring landscapes so was the bubble
wrap a stand-in for the puppies I guess
so in fact the majority of our subjects
popped more bubbles while watching
puppies but not this guy remember him so
how did you feel about seeing the dog
pictures I've always been more of a cat
person it seems sometimes cuteness is a
matter of perspective
[Laughter]
our relationship with destruction is not
a simple one it can release endorphins
and relax
our minds it can amp us up and make us
even more aggressive it can even help us
regulate our emotional reactions to cute
things destruction can be useful it can
be dangerous and it can be a lot of fun
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]